come to this video playing group I
haven't played him for a while
Grandmaster crouppen and he's got a very
low rating here for his son standard
it's a very good gem but bit strange
yeah maybe a bad run I mean it happens
happens to all players it seems okay
we've got a Tory opening toria tech
setting up this very slow ish build up
that hopes to long-term explore to the
parish PL bishops I have absolutely no
peace developed this could it could
prove costly I hope that's not some
things immediately hitting him played
this a bit too quick okay things like
night a four hours at the right moment
okay so he's rerouting to deform
okay I haven't canceled I haven't
canceled yet so i can still go long
probably need to do that slow rotated by
night a force I mean I don't know it's
not not terrible at the moment but but
still got lots of weaknesses to to
attend to so f force is this is Plan
which ok I'm going to Castle long anyway
so better do it now I wonder except for
really that that much of a problem take
him
i mean i understand that i have this f7
weakness and so on but II five is also
week and I have counterplay ideas
related to his also to assess king and
them and and I don't know my queen a
seven though that he has nine f6 he
threatens to take it he definitely
threatens to take it
how do i initiate a counter play against
your five here I go well d 494 looks
like rubbish
I don't know if seven just hang so let's
let's play it like that and go from go
from here some lube takes I was thinking
maybe I can get a rope to g5 in this
position we should be eight as an
interesting move that looks very passive
but it prepares Quincy seven as well
maybe that's not a bad idea I know his
position looks active but I'm not quite
sure the knight on c3 at the bishop they
do nothing and two okay wants to go 95
but that's not really on 95 I have 94
and I just win the night and if I versus
is a weakness okay so look GA to g5 now
and 95 again is answered by 94 look g5
will pick up this pawn now I think I'm
clearly better here unless something is
hitting something something tactical
that I don't see Bishop is sick so
handsome can offer I could have played
94 anyway the night on f4 hangs I should
have at least thought about it well yeah
more sleep at night probably helps with
the quality of the blitz games I feel
I'm overlooking tons of stuff ok so do
let's do this
as planned yeah but I can go here right
check check I'll just pick up stuff or
is there something better now let's do
that come on keep it simple my favorite
motto unfortunately I can tend to not
play play according to it quite often so
can i attack this night with a good
night move to go back here maybe night
e5f just just for the capture on d three
or four Neji form yeah that that's
better Knight g4 is good Here I am 94
for now for Queen to h2 yeah I can take
on d5 I can tell no Queen h2 yeah I'm
kind of irritated him with lots of
things ok the trick here or queen f4
queena for was my original idea he does
not have anything great then i believe
for Queen III for Quincy one
Queen III or any is that better move
generally not so I can give the check
now check and takes on d3 isn't this
winning a piece why isn't this winning a
piece Chang this winning a piece right
yeah white resigns yeah a strange game
strange game yeah I mean I had no
development here absolutely no
development but the position is very
close so it might be okay it might be
okay looks really really I'm like it's
only playing porn and Queen moves but it
is a closed position here I really don't
know the computer says I'm quite
substantially now it goes down only a
slight edge for black yeah it seems it
values the bishop pair pretty highly and
there are definite weaknesses especially
e5
Bishop takes a six is what the computer
as suggesting there is there is a point
yeah this is track a very very strong
attack winning a check I have Queen g5
if I've played that I really have my
doubts for this counter check HERE
blackest your black is winning according
to the comp and I played decently at
least before he was even better at d
foyer taking away c3 for the night but
this is justice also really just a win
right Queen f5 is better yeah possible
but this this was a straightforward way
to play that that kept the the winning
advantage so i'm satisfied here okay
thanks for watching